winter is coming and the pieces have
started moving the house of black and
white you know I do these reviews pretty
much immediately after i watch an
episode so it is very much a first
impressions thing and while I did feel
that the last episode the premiere
episode of the season was good and I
said so the more time i had just think
about it and how little actually
happened in that episode the more it
started to bother me thankfully this
episode does have a bit more happening
we pick up with Brienne of Tarth and
Podrick and I'm still loving the pairing
of them I love their chemistry and sort
of how they don't really mesh together
too well but they're still going to
stick together through thick and thin we
get our first look at Dorne which is
obviously now going to be a fairly major
player in the wake of what happened with
Oberyn Martell last season and possible
fallout from all of that we get our
first look at over at martells brother
who is the actual raining royal in Dorne
and it's hard to get a bead on him he's
obviously a warning for his brother but
you sort of feel the weight of
responsibility on him Owain was very
carefree this guy not getting that vibe
so much now that that's necessarily a
bad thing he shouldn't be exactly like
Oprah but I'm just liking the vibe that
we're getting off of that we pick up
with arya who we did not conceal all
last episode now end of last season she
headed off to find the faceless
assassins and learn from them and that
is where the titular house of black and
white comes in I like how things play
out there i I'm more excited for Aria
than I think any other character I just
love the possibility of what can go on
with her and we also do see the return
of the faceless assassin I I would
normally consider that a spoiler but
given where she was going I think we all
knew he was going to come back in some
capacity and thankfully it is the main
guy that we saw back in season 2 and
it's not the face that he changed to
it's the guy we fell in love with he is
back baby I actually found something to
like about Daario naharis finally he has
good chemistry with grey worm the two of
them a bit like bring
n of Tarzan Podrick they just clash
really well not obviously not in the
same way that Briana and Padre clash but
darn and Horus and grey worm did very
much come at things from a different
mindset from a different angle and I
like the way that they feel with each
other we also get Bronn reintroduced who
was actually a character that I wasn't
sure was ever gonna come back but I like
that he is back I'm like what they
appear to be doing with him and where
he's going to be headed seriously also
turns around for me slightly on this
episode I I got hopeful s episode then
started complaining about her again
almost immediately but I like that she
is sort of really taking charge as much
as she's able to considering that she
has no official power although influence
out the rear end so she's really doing
some very impressive work just situating
herself with as much power as she can
conceivably muster given the fact that
she holds no official power whatsoever
and we're also getting little glimpses
of her sort of new best friend i forget
the character's name but he's the
disgraced meister who looked like he was
trying to frankenstein the mountain back
I back at the end of season 4 they
haven't picked up on that at all but the
characters hanging around and this just
a really odd vibe to the guy and I like
to sort of the hints of what might be
happening with him we pretty much just
get one scene of Tyrion and Varys it's
basically just a touching base e me this
is where they are reminder here's where
they're going but it's a fun scene again
I really like their chemistry so I was
fine with that all this stuff said and
while it's all good and it's pushing
things forward in a good direction there
are two areas that feel like they're
spinning wheels a little bit more one is
up in the north and to be fair there is
stuff that is happening up there with
the Nights Watch with Stannis and with
all of that but it it feels very well it
sort of comes back to what I used to
complain about jon snow before it's very
predictable in terms of where he has
been headed where he's heading and it
just it feels like an obligatory step
for me it didn't have a ceremony that
maybe I should have just cuz it's
something that I've seen coming for
years now but although hopefully without
all the way things will push for
a little bit more where things are
really just wheel spinning at this point
is in marine with the nurse and she is
very much in this man its heart it's
easy to be a conqueror it's hard to be a
ruler thing and while as I said when I
talked about last season I really liked
that four last season I don't like that
she seems to now be stuck in a cycle
where they're just hitting the same
notes and reinforcing the same
difficulties that she's facing I just
hope it's not an indicator for what
she's gonna be dealing with all season I
really hope she's not gonna be stuck in
murine all season cuz I don't care about
marine so I guess it's a little bit of a
mixed bag but I consider it a good step
forward because it didn't it has more
momentum it has more inertia than the
last episode did and on that basis alone
I'm definitely excited for the next
episode why wouldn't I be you know I
talked about some of the pairings that
are happening this season or have
happened recently that I like so let me
ask you this who's sort of your favorite
banter pairing you know some great ones
tiering and bronte random virus now are
you in the Hound when they were going
together what's your favorite sort of
double act little duo that this show is
given us so far whatever it is drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned